I said welcome back I'm Jonathan runts
and we have another series here of
technical challenges so we'll be doing a
special Fabi series where we go over a
lot of fabi's best tactics from
minigames and today's game comes to us
from a game from the millionaire chess
open from 2015 where Fabi was playing
Alexander engine so without further ado
we will jump to the board and we will
get started go ahead and spend a little
bit of time here trying to figure out
what to do as white we will pause in a
second but it is worth pointing out that
white here is completely winning up to
pawns so any reasonable move here should
win for white but can you spot the
knockout blow that Fabi was able to find
and put this game away right away so if
you haven't found it go ahead and pause
your video at this moment but in this
position the move that was just played
by black was h5 which was a very tricky
move you may have noticed the bishop was
attacked and it has a very clever point
that if the bishop takes on h5 blacks
clever point was Bishop to d4 check
forcing the King away from the rook and
for example after King h2 Queen takes f1
you can promote either to a queen or a
rook but in such a position Black has
drawing chances and most likely this
game will result in a type so going back
can you at this point spot it if you
haven't already this is your last chance
to pause the winning move that Fabi
played here was a very fantastic move
rook to f5 simply intending on playing
the move rook h5 whether the pawn
remains there or not so in the game
black did just take this Bishop you're
losing if you don't and you're losing if
you do so he grabs the Bishop rook h5
King g8 and if you haven't seen already
why this is winning you can pause again
here just to make sure you see the point
but the winning combo for white is Queen
to e6 check and after Queen f7 the only
move is to block white now has removing
the defender tactic rook to h8 check and
after it takes you pick up the Queen and
this is indeed where this game came to
its conclusion
so I hope you guys did enjoy that video
if you did go ahead hit like share
subscribe and of course go Fabi
[Music]